hola bienvenidos a este programa
especial la serie en france 24 yo soy
andrés meza muñoz el mundo entero ha
seguido con total atención las
elecciones de eeuu en especial porque el
nuevo presidente joe biden afrontará
importantes desafíos en materia
internacional la administración de
bailén se ha propuesto rehabilitar la
posición de su país como el líder
mundial y de paso retomar vínculos con
sus antiguos socios
daniela hablando nos explica los retos
del mandatario entrante
una misión poco sencilla de hacer mucho
de lo que donald trump decisión yo by
the end tendrá que restablecer los lazos
con los aliados tradicionales de
washington la política exterior de trump
se caracterizó por un giro de 180 grados
en el rol tradicional de eeuu un
alejamiento de la unión europea y
fuertes tensiones entre los miembros de
la otan serán parte de su legado
devolverle al país su liderazgo será la
tarea de antony blinken nominado a la
secretaria de estado no podemos resolver
todos los problemas del mundo solos
necesitamos trabajar con otros países
necesitamos su cooperación necesitamos
su camaradería dar marcha atrás al
retiro de organismos multilaterales como
la organización mundial de la salud y
hacer que eeuu vuelva al acuerdo de
parís para combatir el cambio climático
también son planes en la agenda tengo
muchas ganas de decir bienvenido de
nuevo bienvenido a casa a nuestros
amigos estadounidenses volver al tratado
nuclear alcanzado con irán en 2015 y que
trump decidió abandonar en 2018 será
otro de sus principales retos
me ha dicho que lo haría siempre y
cuando la república islámica vuelva al
estricto cumplimiento de lo acordado
la nueva administración de eeuu traerá
de vuelta el cumplimiento normativo
tanto como antes porque el gobierno
anterior no siguió todas las
regulaciones y fue rebelde ahora podemos
pasar gradualmente de una atmósfera de
amenazas a una atmósfera de
oportunidades en américa latina' la
postura de la administración baiden será
clave a la hora de abordar la pobreza y
la violencia que generan flujos
migratorios desde centroamérica
enfrentará a un fortalecido nicolás
maduro en venezuela después de que el
chavismo se hiciera con el control de la
asamblea nacional y encontrará unas
disminuidas relaciones con cuba tras ser
incluida de nuevo en la lista de países
que apoyan el terrorismo dos temas
claves para la comunidad latina del sur
de eeuu
bardem exigen rendición de cuentas para
rusia se topará con una corea del norte
que amenaza con desarrollar armas
nucleares más avanzadas y con china
queda pendiente de resolver una cruenta
guerra comercial otra
de su predecesor
hablemos de américa latina' para
venezuela eeuu y la comunidad
internacional han buscado elecciones
libres la protección de los derechos
humanos y la atención de la crisis
humanitaria pero qué obstáculos podría
enfrentar joe biden a la hora de abordar
estas situaciones le consultamos a
cynthia arnson directora del programa
latinoamericano del centro de estudios
wilson center en washington dice
los derechos principales es que no hay
realmente un socio en el gobierno de
nicolás maduro está resistiendo
totalmente este tipo de apertura
democrática las herramientas que tienen
los eeuu las sanciones han ayudado a al
colapso económico pero realmente al
parecer han causado más cohesión dentro
del régimen entonces él pues él
como diría la política de presión máxima
no ha tenido sus resultados entonces no
es muy claro lo que los eeuu podría
hacer por sí mismo o en conjunto con
otras regiones o otros países de la
región para enfrentar la grave situación
interna en venezuela
bardem también tiene un plan especial
para américa central arzo nos explica
por qué parte de la política de iovine
hacia centroamérica tiene que ver con
las graves presiones migratorias que hay
desde luego lo que se llama el triángulo
norte el salvador guatemala y honduras y
centroamérica es la única subregión que
contado con su propia sección en
el principal documento de campaña de
iván en donde el comprometió a los eeuu
a gastar miles de millones de dólares
como él encabezó una una política una
iniciativa cuando fue el vicepresidente
durante los tiempos de barack obama
la dificultad obviamente es que bueno
primero el cambio interno es muy lento y
para mejorar la gobernanza la gobernanza
democrática en centroamérica realmente
socios muy cuestionados en el salvador
en honduras y en guatemala entonces no
es para nada fácil buscar cómo gastar
este estos montos de dinero con
transparencia sin corrupción y así hacer
frente a las raíces de la migración las
presiones migratorias de los
centroamericanos hasta aquí la serie de
frases 24 en nuestras próximas emisiones
estaremos a bordo
otros retos que le esperan a biden en
temas como cambio climático y economía
quédense con nosotros
[Música]